[Applause]
[Music]
yeah you better clap
so after tuesday's democrat bloodbath
you see more finger-pointing than a
johnny depp divorce
and most of it is directed at all those
damn evil white people
right tiff
this isn't about enthusiasm this isn't
about democrats not doing enough to
exercise their base and this definitely
is not about messaging or even about
beloved
this is about the fact that a good chunk
of voters out there are okay with white
supremacy let's call a thing a thing
actually scratch that
scratch what
that's kind of gross maybe maybe get an
ointment
so yeah the democrats lost because
voters love white supremacy especially
the 54 of hispanic white supremacists
who voted for yunkan
those damn hispanic white supremacists
again with their white supremacist tango
and their white supremacist tamales
you've heard this white supremacist crap
all over at msnbc this network was the
worst idea bill gates ever had besides
hanging out with jeffrey epstein
i shouldn't have said hanging
anyway
too soon too soon
that place that network lies to their
viewers more than the guy who sold me
those blue pills on craigslist
rock hard my ass
but they blame whiteness for virginia's
election while saying crt doesn't exist
it makes me miss the clinton era when
the dems were really good at lying so
cross was filling in for the homophobic
blogger turned pundit joy reed who had
said the same thing
it was education right which is code for
white parents don't like the idea of
teaching about race
yes because if there's one thing missing
in our educational system it's america's
history of racism yeah and what's
missing in a strip club is the smell of
desperation
and baby powder
it is funny though how could someone
named joy reid be so joyless and not
read
there are countless articles out there
on crt and how often it's being taught
in schools so joy and tiffany said the
same thing like people who plan to lie
often will it's like msnbc have only one
brain in the freezer and in the handoff
they must have dropped it numerous times
but what if they're right in fact there
are lots of voters who are okay with
white supremacy it's just that they vote
democrat and not just because they
supported governor northam who either
wore blackface or a clan hood he never
did tell us which either way no white
sheets after labor day ralph
it's okay to laugh at that oh okay don't
laugh but the most affluent places in
america are arlington fairfax and
loudoun counties which are all in
virginia there people make six figures
or even seven figures they're the kind
of folks who can afford hunter biden's
artwork and drug habit
and they vote democrat overwhelmingly
knowing that only leads to paying much
higher taxes as the new york times
points out affluent suburbs went bluer
than a smurf choking on a marble
they didn't say that i did but boccola
won 77 of the vote in arlington so these
are voters who know they're going to pay
way more under a democrat but they do it
anyway whether it's in taxes at the gas
pump or buying medical devices online
fyi catheters come in handy when you
can't make it to the bathroom
trust me
so while pocketbook issues matter to
blacks they don't matter to these rich
white liberal racists ask yourself if
you vote a republican are you just
trying to save some money so you can
fill your tank with gas or are you
racist
maybe everyone who drives is racist but
the rich white liberal racist can afford
stuff like climate change spending
defunding the cops unregulated
immigration coveted lockdowns and no
cash bail but no one else really can
just ask minneapolis where a majority of
blacks just voted against replacing the
police department getting rid of the
police is a popular idea with white
college kids in safe neighborhoods but
not so much with people who might be
murdered see unlike working class blacks
rich white liberal racists they can
handle it when you're white and rich you
can vote for anything that will destroy
an urban area faster than a case of
whippets on cats brain cells
you can raise taxes on the white liberal
racists they can handle it you could
defund the police they can handle it
they're in gated communities and can
afford private security and it's okay if
their security has guns
immigration they love the cheap labor it
takes care of their hedges and it really
only affects border states right covered
lockdowns are fine they have enough cash
tucked away to endure a few years
watching the view in their underpants
or they have government jobs where
they're used to doing nothing
no cash bail they love that virtue
signal look how it empties evil prisons
especially since those repeat offenders
end up in the bronx or other places the
white rich liberal racist only sees in
gritty movies starring other rich white
liberals who can't shoot guns
and at least one who can
at crt
white rich liberal racists don't mind it
because all their kids go to pricey
private schools just like terry
mcauliffe's brats they love school
choice as long as poor people can't
afford it but at least the public school
kids are getting laid by their teachers
something i missed
why did i go to catholic school
anyway but you got to wonder even if
you're a white rich liberal why wouldn't
you also want secure borders school
choice and safe streets that way
minorities could also make a better life
for themselves is it because the white
rich liberal is racist perhaps they need
minorities to have problems the
government causes so they'll look to the
government to solve them i wonder what
the angry black male thinks
[Music]
all right
one two three
four
yes
with hotels new york i own it one
thousand
dollars only reason you're winning is
because of racism i'm sorry no the
reason why what racism i'm winning
because you rolled a six one two three
four five six let me just stop you right
there what kind of racism are you
talking about okay the game that we are
playing is racist so white supremacists
are helping me a black man win at
monopoly
that's the game right
i'm playing monopoly what game are you
playing
oh my god
so the leftist media claims the white
working class are racist for voting for
republicans when it's the white working
class that shares the same concerns that
the black working class does and that's
about crime education taxes and
inflation fact is the blame whitey
strategy provides cover for the white
rich liberal racists racism may come in
many forms but it's not always a noose
on a doorknob sometimes it's a caucasian
progressive with seven figures in the
bank and an illegal nanny in the guest
room
she hosts a youtube show called the
weekly dumpster fire not to be confused
with reliable sources with brian stelter
comedian and host of dumpster fire
bridge and fedex
so southern she deep fries her deep
fryer fox business anchor
mcdowell
her pets complain that she gets hair
everywhere
foxy's contributor cat tim
and he's made more people say uncle than
the octomom's brother
my massive sidekick and the nwa world
television champion tyrus
all right
i thought that was a pretty good
introduction tyrus
cat's writing him now isn't she
so what what did you make of this uh uh
how the media like let me put it this
way that election gives you like one day
of editorial content for a tv show but
it's the meltdown response that gives
you like a month of stuff well you know
i had i had called this weeks before
i've been saying on here you keep
messing with moms and dads yeah you mess
with our education and you mess with our
police department we're going to show up
we're going to do the extra work right
and i warned him
in the really real world this stuff
matters not your fake fantasy ninth
place woke-ism that no one wants and
we saw it in a place in a fashion across
the board even the new jersey race came
down to the wire when they shouldn't
have they sent a message
parents were like we're going to be
heard we're going to be respected we
want to get back to work and the
democrats said
i'm sorry i don't understand it's
oh
we weren't progressive enough
[Laughter]
we
weren't
pushing
enough they didn't hear us the
white racist
showed up and i would just like to say
yes you're exactly right aoc
let's step up let's add another
50 woke-ism
this is the campaign strategy
well i don't do this often
well done
let's keep this going let's take this in
the midterms turn that progressive
vocaism up because we're thirsty for it
we can't wait we i i love it my life is
so easy everything's racist i don't have
to do anything i can wait to check and
if i fail and if anyone calls me out on
my laziness they're racist too
ladies and gentlemen utopia yes
yo
audience applauding racism i like that
do you know bridgette we've made it
yes
i sometimes i wonder if wouldn't it be
better if we all just said we're racist
and then it would be because
right now just we made it yes and that
would completely destroy this narrative
what do you think of this how do you how
do you see this i just love that white
supremacy is when you vote for the wrong
white guy
yeah your white supremacy i don't know
it seems like when when all you have is
a hammer everything is literally racism
and it just seems like people are over
it they're not being bullied anymore
they're tired of hearing this they're
not scared of being called bigots
they're and this is problematic because
you don't want to destroy these words
right but they have no meaning anymore
what are you supposed to do if you're
just non-stop being told that everything
oh could never be anything that they did
let's not look at policy let's not look
at the fact that kids didn't go to
school for 18 months there could never
be any possible other reason other than
racism and that just seems like a losing
strategy and it continues to be it's a
winning strategy
a winning strategy but there are two
points that you made that are that are
that are together and now i forgot what
they were but they were really good oh
obviously maybe i'm not the one doing
the whip it's great
i've got joe biden disease no it's um
the fact that what happens if you come
across a real bigot and you call him a
bigot then it means nothing and they
could go oh like a real big can go oh
this is just woken up right it's just
woken so but that's that's the scary
part but the other thing is the fearless
part which is that everybody was so
scared of of responding to being accused
but now they're not
so it's like because it's meaningless so
that's the good there's the bad part
there's the good part
digging that is quite a dress yeah thank
you yes i stopped wearing my clip-in
bangs after ten years
for you
but to what you were talking about not
only are you a white supremacist if you
vote for the wrong guy you're a white
supremacist if you vote for a black
woman yes the first black woman ever
elected to statewide office but zealots
got a zealot yeah they're not going to
admit they're wrong and so when somebody
votes for someone they don't like
they're going to call you a racist
rather than waking up to the fact that
their world view is not in step with
what's going on in the rest of the
country and they love to use that hammer
but that little now it's like a little
rubber racist hammer that nobody is is
frightened of they have used it so much
so falsely so maliciously that people
it's like bring your hammer at me i'm
not cowering you can call me a racist
i'm not bending down i'm not asking for
forgiveness the only bigots like how do
you spot a bigot well they're the left
is going to cover up for them because
they're in their own party yeah so i
did my usual research and they did a
fact ap did a fact check last year as
biden was running for president biden
did not eulogize a former kkk grand
wizard yes
robert byrd however they found out was
an exalted cyclops and was a recruiter
for the clan yes that's that that's
different that changes everything only a
recruiter for the clan yeah it's not a
grand dragon it's just the guy that gets
the grenade
you know he's still handicapped he only
has one eye
it can't be so quick that his racism is
through a skewed lens
that's not as strong when you only have
one eye yeah and think about how
insecure you have to be to call yourself
exalted i mean i would just go by
cyclops cat yeah no
that's what we're going with all right
look
the problem is they have too much
they're too secure they're not insecure
enough like we all have those friends
that are you know they're still single
they don't want to be single and it's so
obvious to everyone why they are single
but they can't accept that so they're
like you know i'm just men are so
intimidated by me because i'm such a
strong woman it's like you sure it's not
because you get so drunk and crap
yourself every time you go out
like they won't hear that i mean their
whole platform is we're going to take
all of your money and then also your
kids
and people don't vote for them and
they're like racist it's truly that
delusional and until they confront it
nothing's going to change cat makes a
phenomenal point why thank you because
no and
it used to be in my crew the brothers we
always had one brother that his name was
either rahim or whatever reason and he
would always everything was racist yeah
it didn't matter we sit in a restaurant
and be like they had the menus one where
they showed us a menu because we were
racist
because you were 15 minutes late because
the man the lights outside were racist
they always turn red when i get there
why is that bro cause i'm because we
black dog and we're like bruh
you know what i'm saying it was just
that one guy
apparently now he's got a whole pope no
the one guy ended up at msnbc but it's a
woman
go figure all right hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else